[Música]
hola quería partir con un par de
preguntas gustaría preguntarles quién
siente que está en proceso de cambio o
transformación
heller ante su manito
ten siempre que hay una tensión entre lo
que hoy día hace y lo que le gustaría
estar haciendo
quien siente que el mundo se está
poniendo cada vez más volátil e incierto
complejo y ambiguo
vine al lugar a quien siente
en mi experiencia la transformación
humana la reinvención humana se produce
cuando el dolor de cambiar es menor que
el dolor de permanecer igual
cuando el dolor de cambiar en menor que
requiere de una atención entre un
sistema de creencias y un sistema nuevo
no muy claro que pareciera estar
naciendo permanentemente
un sistema de creencias
lo podemos llamar un paradigma
un paradigma contiene al menos estas
tres dimensiones fundamentales
nuestras prácticas simbolizada por esas
manos son una mano pero el dibujo
una segunda dominio clave son nuestras
ideas y estructuras que acompañan a
nuestras prácticas simbolizadas por un
cerebro yo estuviera me dijeron que
parecía una oveja eso pero es un cerebro
y estas dos dimensiones solamente hacen
que el paradigma se transforme cuando la
tercera entra en acción que son nuestras
éticas y espiritualidad representadas
por el corazón
y entonces esto ocurre todo el tiempo
todo el tiempo estamos modificando
nuestros paradigmas y yo diría que
un paradigma crece hasta que llega un
punto donde empieza a tiritar para luego
decaer y transformarse en un paradigma
emergente
el prisma emergente comienza cuando el
paradigma dominante empieza a tambalear
les ha pasado
después que recurren a sus memorias para
poder confirmar esto esto nos pasa todo
el tiempo ocurre en distintos niveles de
escala día e iu ocurre en dimensiones
individual colectiva y ecosistémica
viéndome compartir con ustedes
en poquitos minutos la historia de los
últimos 60 mil años de experiencia
humana
quiero solamente compartir como hemos
modificado profundamente nuestros
paradigmas de comportamiento yo diría
que hemos tenido al menos tres grandes
cambios de paradigma en estos últimos 60
mil años
el primer gran cambio corresponde al
paso de ser cazadores-recolectores a ser
agricultores
y hace unos 60.000 años cuando éramos
cazadoras recolectoras
el periodismo fundamental
sobre el cual funcionamos era que
algunos cazaban
evidentemente otros recolectaban nos
sentábamos en círculo alrededor del
fuego y compartíamos nuestras historias
compartíamos nuestros sueños y tomamos
decisiones colectivamente
en esa época aprendimos a hacer talleres
de suculentas
y el tipo de economía de ese momento
pasábamos nuestra economía en la
economía del regalo era un tipo de
economía de retorno inmediato es que no
acumulábamos nada el tipo de conciencia
era una conciencia horizontal algunos
hablan de que era una conciencia
paradójica por qué
surfeamos en la paradoja del mundo
natural
la espiritualidad se representaba a
través de pertenecerle a la tierra
y la muerte no era una no necesitamos
darle un significado a la muerte porque
la muerte era parte del ciclo de la vida
pero hace unos 12.000 años atrás todo
comenzó a cambiar
este tránsito de ser
cazadores-recolectores a ser
agricultores fue clave
nuestras formamos en agricultores cuando
comenzamos a permanecer en aquellos
lugares donde la tierra se lograba
regenerar sola en los deltas de algunos
ríos y empezamos a permanecer ahí
nuestra economía del regalo y de retorno
inmediato se transformó por una economía
transaccional y de retorno
porque empezamos a acumular el grano por
ejemplo el tipo de conciencia empezó a
modificarse profundamente
algunos hablan de que transformamos la
experiencia de la paradoja en el
complejo de autoridad sagrada la
espiritualidad la sacamos de la tierra y
empezamos a mirar hacia el cielo porque
necesitamos empezar
a explicarnos ya a construir
significados prácticamente de todo
incluso de la muerte
entonces este paradigma de la
agricultura empezó a profundizarse aquí
vemos el este primer gran cambio algunos
llaman a este periodo el periodo del
gran olvido porque pareciera que se nos
hubiera olvidado algunas cosas que no
creamos en ese momento fundamentalmente
me gustaría contarles que generamos
cuatro patrones que nos han llevado al
estado de sobrecarga que hoy día estamos
experimentando
esos cuatro patrones son el primero
empezamos a generar las primeras
jerarquías primero fueron sacerdotes en
él
en la cúspide de la jerarquía luego
fueron faraones luego fueran reyes y
luego fueran fueron empresarios
y así hemos ido permanentemente desde
ese momento construyendo jerarquías que
nos han generado un tipo de cultura de
el poder sobre las personas y el poder
sobre la naturaleza
la jerarquía funcionan solamente si hay
un tipo de campo social específico que
es el campo social del miedo
las oraciones o este mismo
comportamiento lo traemos hoy día a
nuestras organizaciones la organización
es más que era jerárquica
son organizaciones que funcionan con
campos sociales de miedo
lo tercero el tercer patrón fundamental
fue la supresión de lo femenino porque
empezamos a construir sociedades
patriarcales
y como cuarto elemento la aseveración de
ser humano con la naturaleza algo clave
para el devenir humano entonces este
primer gran cambio comenzó hace unos
12.000 años atrás y se empezó a
profundizar para llegar al segundo gran
cambio que es el paso de ser
agricultores hacia una sociedad de
crecimiento industrial
y la sociedad creció metiendo este al
basha su paradigma en el crecimiento
infinito en un planeta que es finito
y
y es el tipo de paradigma que nos tiene
hoy día en un estado de sobrecarga y
colapso en algunos lugares
entonces hoy día estamos yo diría que en
la mitad de un tercer gran cambio no sé
si lo perciben pero es un cambio que
requiere la conservación de algo muy
particular a mí me encanta pensar que es
la conservación de la vida en todas sus
formas y puedes reconectar con la
profunda interconexión e
interdependencia de todos los fenómenos
que ese es el momento en el que estamos
estos son mis padres mis ancestros
inmediatos
para mí representan 13 mil 800 millones
de años de creatividad y de
transfiguración del universo representan
al mismo tiempo unos 4 mil millones de
años de evolución de la vida en el
planeta y representan al mismo tiempo
algunos en un par de millones de años de
coevolución para transformarnos en seres
humanos que experimentan amor
experimentan emociones
en mí también ya que han estado tan
presente en los padres a cada permite
también una historia de mi padre
un día de noviembre del año 89 llegué a
mi casa y fue a salvar a mi papá que
estaba en la salita viendo televisión
entré a la salita lo miro y estaba con
lágrimas en los ojos y la primera vez
que veía llorar amigos
luego va hola qué te pasa
el sin de pegar la vista del televisor
me dice pero ni mi papá era chico los
chicos no pueden pronunciar la erre por
lata cuando me dice rollo me decía perón
pero ni mejor nunca pensé que iba a
estar vivo para ver esto miré la
pantalla y habían unos tipos rompiendo
un muro era el muro de berlín le dije
papá para poder ver a tu hermano y pensé
guau vamos a poder conocer a nuestro
primo
y claro mi papá dejo todo el año 49 y se
escapó de un sistema que él pensó que
era perpetuo
era permanente vivió toda su vida con la
idea de que sus parientes no eran
accesibles y usted que de un momento a
otro
el mundo se cayó y después de 41 años
volvió a ver a su hermano mi tío pepe
nosotros al poquito tiempo conocimos a
nuestro primo milán y su familia
preciosa que tiene
y pase
y el muro de berlín representa la
emergencia de la profunda interconexión
e interdependencia de todos los
fenómenos que ocurrieron para generar
ese gran cambio
representan el dolor del cambio cuando
el dolor de cambiar es menor que el
dolor de permanecer igual era imposible
predecir la caída del muro
y a mí me pasa que
siento
lo mismo que experimento en mi papá
mirando esa televisión siento en este
momento del tiempo que nunca pensé que
iba a estar vivo para ver el gran cambio
dentro del cual estamos sumergidos
y me acuerdo que experimenté dolor por
el mundo y mi cuerpo aquí experimenté
dolor por la ceguera humana
e
y quise plasmar en esta pequeña décima
lo que me pasa con este tema del
paradigma dominante
pero hay una dominante que sobrecarga
profesa ya no mira la belleza que
aparece en un instante como el sol en el
levante
ya comienza el desenredó y con él se
larga el miedo por milenios encastrada
que por tanto acumulado el gran savia se
queda ciego
siento que estamos en un momento de
ceguera profunda el respecto de cómo
deberíamos estar en el mundo cuál es el
paradigma mediante el cual de diésemos
funcional
y me pasa también qué
así como nunca pensé que iba estar vivo
para ver esto siempre que hay ciertos
patrones cuando hablamos de reinvención
humana cuando hablamos de regeneración
me gustaría compartir con ustedes
algunos patrones que llevo descubriendo
en el tiempo que tienen mucha relación
con los procesos de cambio de
transformación primero antes
y aumentan la complejidad tratar de
vivir simplemente lo más simple que sea
posible simplificar como simplificamos
nuestra vida
antes
en esta desconexión con el mundo natural
como poder reconectar volver a eliminar
esa separación que hay entre nosotros y
la naturaleza en la naturaleza he
descubierto muchísimas respuestas
somos de muchas maneras la naturaleza
teniendo una experiencia humana
construir comunidades si hay algo
relevante en estos prueba y salió en
alguna otra charla la relevancia de
construir comunidad los cambios se
pueden lograr mucho más fácilmente en
conjunto
trabaja por la dignidad de los
ecosistemas necesitamos reconectar con
un mundo donde podamos recuperar la
dignidad tanto humana como no humana
desarrolla la creatividad a niveles
donde nunca antes hemos llegado eso es
lo que necesitamos volver a reconectar
para que la creatividad sea posible
necesitamos intentar crear campos
sociales de confianza suspendiendo el
miedo de todas las maneras que podamos
esto no lo podemos hacer sólo que
también requerimos del patrón
fundamental que es la humildad para
entender que necesitamos juntarnos para
poder producir los cambios que queremos
ver
y finalmente el ritmo el ritmo es un
patrón clave lo acabamos de ver en la
charla anterior cada uno tiene su ritmo
que aún no tiene su ritmo de cambio
entonces volviendo a estos tres momentos
de cambios profundos
el primer gran cambio ha demorado miles
de años en producirse todavía hay por
ahí algunas etnias transformándose de
cazadores-recolectores agricultores en
papúa nueva guinea en australia en el
amazona
el segundo gran cambio y un gran cambio
que ha durado algunos cientos de años
que el tercer gran cambio el cambio en
el que estamos no puede demorar más de
una o dos décadas
como es el mundo que le queremos dejar a
las próximas generaciones qué tipo de
reinvención de transformación es
necesaria para que se ocurra
como me gustaría ser recordado seremos
recordados como la generación que logró
el cambio a tiempo
bienvenidos a los años más desafiantes
de la historia de la presencia humana
sobre la tierra muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
a
hola
[Música]